[Música]
y hoy vamos directo a santiago la
policía de chile detuvo a héctor llaitul
uno de los principales líderes radicales
mapuche el líder a la coordinadora
arauco malleco que reivindica
periódicamente ataques incendiarios en
el sur del país que es precisamente el
epicentro del conflicto entre la etnia
mapuche y las empresas que están en
tierras consideradas ancestrales vamos
con nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
patricia bienvenida a este segmento de
directo américa cuéntenos quién es
héctor llaitul y que representan tanto
él como la coordinadora arauco malleco
en el conflicto mapuche
buenas noches pues mira un impacto ha
causado en chile la dirección de héctor
llaitul una cara conocida por todos como
una de las figuras que representan la
reivindicación de la lucha armada en el
conflicto mapuche para toda la serie de
reclamos de esteban desde la
reivindicación sobre la restitución de
las tierras ancestrales que datan desde
hace varios siglos hasta una serie de
otro tipo de reclamos héctor de itunes
la coordinadora arauco malleco se han
atribuido en la mayor cantidad es una de
las organizaciones que se atribuyen de
las mayores cantidades de ataques
incendiarios que suceden cada vez con
más frecuencia en el sur del país según
cifras de la ministra de interior el
pasado mes decía sitges en los ataques
incendiarios pasaron de 400 a 1700 en
los últimos cuatro años algo que ha ido
incrementando en frecuencia contra
maquinarias pero también contra predios
en ocasiones contra trabajadores que se
ha producido con cada vez más frecuencia
que ha llevado al gobierno de gabriel
boric a decretar el estado de excepción
en el país para qué militares puedan
ayudar a controlar un poco este tipo de
ataques en ese lugar y ante el
incremento de los ataques explíquenos
cuáles han sido las reacciones al
arresto y que puede implicar esto en el
conflicto además teniendo en cuenta las
posibles repercusiones en el plebiscito
del 4 de septiembre en el que los
chilenos votarán si aprueban o rechazan
una nueva constitución
la reacción ha sido transversal en todo
en el arco político de lo tanto del
oficialismo como de la oposición se han
alegrado que el estado de derecho
funcione algunos han reclamado que esto
se ha producido tarde que la justicia
tarda pero finalmente llega y todos
están bastante satisfechos del derecho
que se ha producido la detención de
aitor que había incrementado el tono de
sus manifestaciones en las últimas
semanas ya había confesado públicamente
que participa en el robo ilegal de la
madera uno de los negocios muy
importantes que sucede en el país y como
de hasta cien millones de dólares
anuales se espera lo que pueda ocurrir
mañana en el control de detención en la
presentación de los cargos también que
pueda haber una que pueda haber en la
noche peligro en la zona que pueda haber
una serie de resarcimientos de mayor
cantidad de atentados como ya ha
anunciado también la cam de su lado y lo
que pueda ocurrir como bien señalas de
cara al plebiscito puesto que al
gobierno se le había acusado de ser un
poco débil o un poco con la figura de
héctor llaitul es un golpe fuerte por
parte también de la fiscalía que por fin
ha recabado la según dijo para que
podrían mostrar que mostrarían la
implicación de tul en los delitos
mencionados